[ __ ] coolers for six hours taking up
trash put them in the back we'll be lazy
okay get in the back four four four four
four six hours eight hours man yes I
refused to meet come learn a little wage
[ __ ] hey you guys have papers how many
times have we been guilted into the old
mantra that illegal immigrants are doing
the jobs Americans just won't take I see
people gathered on street corners okay
some guy in a truck comes over and says
I'll pay you $10 if you work all day
you're doing the jobs you don't want to
can do if you kick every Latino out of
this country and who is going to be
cleaning your toilet Donald Trump we
should pay them a decent salary because
this is America you want to get rid of
illegal immigrants quitting this country
has been importing new slave labor
they're competing with Americans who
wouldn't accept $10 a day to work in
those jobs but is that actually true
it's no secret that many law-abiding
Americans feel left out in the cold with
some studies like this one from Harvard
showing an annual earnings decrease of
close to $1,400 due to illegal
immigration but hey if these aliens are
doing worse jobs for lower pay isn't it
our own fault we decided to put it to
the test and head on down to our local
illegal employment office good news for
us is right off the bat it sounded like
wages we'd be thrilled to take you may
400 feet
damn bro $400 in three days damn bro
that's like 280 take-home undocumented
people in this country do contribute to
America and they do so by paying their
taxes only really how much ninety paying
taxes I'm sure I'll team up
okay wait so this guy's take-home was
four hundred dollars for three days and
this guy wouldn't take anything less
than one hundred and sixty dollars for
six hours
yeah for six hours again for six hours
and I had a new one thirty let's do some
math here one hundred and sixty dollars
divided by 6 equals about $26.66 an hour
tax-free accounting for an average work
week of around forty hours that comes
out to somewhere around one thousand
sixty six forty cents per week he could
make anywhere from between forty five to
fifty six thousand dollars per year
tax-free add to that fact that 15
percent of illegal immigrants in Texas
alone are in some form of welfare and
heck you could live like a Mayan King
all of the taxpayers dime of course
costing us an additional whopping fifty
billion dollars per year but pointing
out math is racist and we wouldn't want
to be racist right we should learn to be
more inclusive like our loving Mexican
brethren 20 million winners over
plummets ready to help you LaRocco
they'd like this not
while you along anyway
okay nothing cool man cool cool cool bro
okay so they kind of hate white people
who among us doesn't
turns out they liked it even less when
some Americans like us were willing to
do the job for less than $25 an hour
tax-free 2,140 okay 110 110 you're not
gonna do 100 right we'll do 100 all
right one sec we're 128 now we're 100
we're cheaper 100 no one's doing 100
here not unreasonable heck we just
wanted to fight for $1,500 I know
premium so yeah we got two will do for
ninety anybody would tell me why bro
it's not like that seventy all day
tonight
very late look at 65 66 creeping into
that one owner for six hours we'll pick
it think you know I got tapes at home
bro I'll just take you all day do not
work not to private $85 okay okay what
up right now what do we learn here
mostly that contrary to what the media
tells us these individuals don't
necessarily have a great affinity for
American pride paying taxes white people
or a good-old competition and as for
just how we knew that these people were
here illegally call it a hunch
hey you guys have papers
you guys have papers I need papers you
have papers he's gonna collage you
[ __ ]
[Music]
like this video subscribe by clicking
the subscribe button it's acted sinesses
circle now it used to be a square which
most buttons aren't squares let's it's
on a phone they're square buttons on
phones with most buttons are circles you
understand what I'm talking about or
watch the recommended video which is
popping up in a box or subscribe at
lateral credit comm slash mug club join
the mug Club so you can get the daily
show and that means that you are not
beholden to the YouTube censoring
overlords so let's be honest you like
being there where you are under their
thumb power bottom you